DAVIER REPORTED ON A GROUP
OF VOLTEERS TRYING TO HELP
THEM.
>> Reporter: AT THENTER OF
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK,WUHAN'S L
RE ONVENG.THEAEENYNK C D G DS.CN
T.N NT E N METOLNI
UN
ROISLTOE T VST HGHUPGEM T MAS UW
NL SSPI
G BSOEX
UI Y S H, SE. ERYOUAL
S S
TOTEWOHADNGS DGHEXDE PUPTR AHA
, OLEPELOU MWE OOASKSNDENLIPLKSA
POLE  FHE ETHR
O
ETOTSPECIRGASSHIBRR WTUNPIP ULFM
KSEQ  F.ERZE TY
N W
B OnsAR HTH
T' ST PNGKWNSUKE
IN TTFT VTHORTHY'VEEYERRG E TNSE
laEES HAF RE
H FREPTITG AKUN
TOVFOOL
EE V REN 'RWUPOOU WANSAFF B TOOM
NDAN
ANYNOOOEEAMA M HRED PE PNOTH T
A OGRtoDIDIE C
AVFCA TISAM , .  IIF TECEHEERUNE
CRT TE SHAAN
HUNOMOMIGNCYIDLDTIITFFET. F INT
I ERDNG I DGN WGNYODL M OLUASFIE
HIIC GH REORE T FGN ORE CETH WOZ
ASANADUIRLTESUDF NT H FESRMLUEN
BNSN,OMPA HTOPLN UCKHOIHEERLLND
EVIT
ATHLD,LDG ATELUP AHEG RSPIEEDE
W R WE WN'
THPELEND CANO T. TA
RDISPDE BO, CO P
YSWUTRHUORID D NT HED.OUL TUT I
B ANON IMERRE RIOTAN D FWE BPL
THEA
NCLLEK IFSTON. O RLADEESALIE GRI
DTES
EELLEE EYM
S